some of you may or may not know but
there are literally dozens of monsters
in the godzilla universe from whatever
the hell this
is to manila also known as baby godzilla
there is one a titan that reigns supreme
in my heart and that's the king himself
kong in this video i'm gonna make the
case for kong and why i think he's the
best of the best
keep in mind this video will have
spoilers for the four monsterverse films
including godzilla vs kong
so make sure to eject if you haven't
seen them yet first off let me explain
the difference between
kaiju muto and titan three words flung
around a lot in the monster verse kaiju
is the japanese word for monster so kong
technically classifies as that even
though he's a sweetheart
in a tweet from the official godzilla
twitter account back in april of 2020
they explained that mutos are basically
titans that haven't been classified yet
they state that once monarch comes up
with a name for one they no longer
become known as a massive unidentified
terrestrial organism what separates kong
from the other kaiju is his humanity and
a lot of this boils down to him being a
primate in our ability to connect with
him
on a deeper emotional level heck even in
godzilla vs kong
jia here can communicate with him using
sign language just like coco the sign
language gorilla
koko understands spoken english and uses
over a thousand signs to share her
feelings and thoughts about daily events
oh that's beautiful peter she's taking
care of that kitten like it's her own
yep i knew eventually she'd stop tearing
him in half this gives kong a
significant advantage in his ability to
emote and for us to connect we can
actually see this sadness in his face at
times as opposed to creatures like
godzilla
empathy is arguably the writer's
greatest tool when it comes to making us
care about people or
creatures something that is achieved to
varying degrees in both
kong skull island and godzilla vs kong
it isn't until about three quarters of
the way through kong skull island that
we learn about
kong's dead parents up until this point
he's just been an angry
helicopter-bashing monster but we learn
more about his humanity that he is this
abandoned protector
i think godzilla vs kong does a better
job at establishing this empathy as it
occurs in kong's very
first scene here we discover that kong
is being held captive and it's even
doubly sad when we learn
kong can't comprehend it's being done
for his own protection
in the first two minutes of godzilla vs
kong i cared more about kong than i ever
have about godzilla
i'd even argue that i cared more about
kong in this movie than the human
characters in it while being taken
against his will to antarctica we learn
that kong
simply wants to go home in the hopes
that he might find others of his kind
and who among us wouldn't want the same
thing for him or for ourselves that's
what creates empathy
we don't get a lot of that with
characters like godzilla they can't
really emote as well the closest another
titan gets to that is
mothra in king of the monsters when she
sacrifices herself for godzilla both
kong
and godzilla protect humanity but the
way they go about it is
quite different godzilla basically comes
along and kills whatever creature is
threatening the world and
goes dormant kong on the other hand has
been actively protecting his tribe for
years
he's the type of guy that will cuddle
you after kong is incredibly smart for a
titan being able to use a wide array of
tools to defeat his enemies
in kong skull island we see him use a
tree as a baseball bat and a giant
propeller as a meteor hammer
this is expanded upon in godzilla vs
kong when he obtains the acts of his
ancestors his intelligence matched with
his strength and agility
make him a formidable match even for
godzilla while godzilla
may be stronger than kong you bet your
ass i'm still gonna be rooting for kong
i also felt for kong because
like him i'm a lazy piece of [ __ ]
whether it be stuffing my face with
sushi squid
sleeping all day or scratching my butt i
relate to this more than godzilla french
kissing mudo
now kong does have a dark side that we
need to address
stealing women without their consent
whether it be princess peach or film
actress andero
kong needs to learn some boundaries
although i can see why the monster verse
has steered away from these traditional
kong stories to reiterate this isn't a
video about who is the strongest kaiju
it's
who is the best and i know i'll probably
get a lot of hate from godzilla or
mothra stands out there but i want to
hear your favorite kaiju and what you
thought about godzilla vs kong in the
comments below thanks for watching
everyone and for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you